ELLEN AND HELPING ME FIND MY
TRUTH AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
MISSION, TOTALLY.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
YESTERDAY THE MAYOR OF
BALTIMORE, MARYLAND, ANNOUNCED
THE CITY WILL HELP STUDENTS GET
TO THE MARCH FOR OUR LIVES, THAT
GUN-CONTROL RALLY RALLY IN
WASHINGTON LATER THIS MONTH.
>> IT IS ALL ABOUT HEARING THE
VOICES OF YOUNG PEOPLE, AND SO
WE ARE TAKING 60 BUSES FROM
BALTIMORE CITY -- FROM BALTIMORE
CITY, BECAUSE WE WANT YOUR
VOICES TO BE HEARD IN
WASHINGTON, D.C..
>> Laura: JOINING US NOW IS
THE MAYOR OF BALTIMORE,
CATHERINE PUGH WHO SUPPORTED AND
ADDRESSED HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS
WHO WALKED OUT OF THEIR
CLASSROOMS YESTERDAY DEMANDING
GUN CONTROL LEGISLATION.
IT IS GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THE
SHOW.
I SO APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
TONIGHT.
TELL US ABOUT WHAT YOUR GOAL IS
HERE IN BALTIMORE.
THIS MARCH IS GOING TO TAKE
PLACE IN A FEW WEEKS IN
WASHINGTON.
BUT WHAT DO YOU WANT TO ACHIEVE
BY HELPING THE STUDENTS GO DOWN?
>> SO FIRST LET ME SAY THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITE AND IT'S GOOD TO
BE HERE THIS EVENING WITH YOU.
OUR GOAL IS TO ALLOW YOUNG
PEOPLE'S VOICES TO BE HEARD.
WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WERE MARCHING DOWN TO
CITY HALL, BUT WHEN WE DID HEAR
THAT THEY WERE COMING I THOUGHT
IT IMPORTANT TO RECEIVE THEM
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE THESE MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE AFRAID AND
FRIGHTENED TO BE IN OUR
CLASSROOMS, OR ASKING YOU TO
HELP THEM GO OUT AND WANT TO
HAVE YOU HEAR THEIR VOICES, THEY
DID NOT NECESSARILY EVEN KNOW
ABOUT THE MARGIN WASHINGTON,
SOME OF THEM, BUT MANY OF THEM
WANTED THEIR VOICES TO BE HEARD
IN TERMS OF THE VIOLENCE THAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR CITY, IN OUR
COUNTRY AND THROUGHOUT THIS
NATION.
THEY WANT THEIR VOICES TO BE
HEARD AND WE THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THEM, TO
WELCOME THEM AND AT THE SAME
TIME WE REACHED OUT AS A CITY
CLOSE TO WASHINGTON ASKING IF WE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN HELPING
YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., SO THAT THEIR
VOICES COULD BE HEARD AS IT
RELATES TO GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND AS YOU WELL KNOW,
WE'VE HAD SOME 320 DIFFERENT
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS SINCE 2013 AND
WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE ARE ASKING YOU
ARE YOU PROTECTING OUR SCHOOLS,
ARE YOU PROTECTING US, ARE YOU
GOING TO MAKE SURE WE ARE SAFE?
JUST IN OUR STATE ALONE, OUR
GOVERNOR HAS ISSUED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO HELP SCHOOLS TO
BECOME MORE SAFE.
>> Laura: 343 MURDERS IN
BALTIMORE IN 2017.
DEVASTATING NUMBER.
HORRIFIC VIOLENCE.
SOME OF THE TOUGHEST GUN LAWS IN
THE COUNTRY AND MARYLAND, WE ALL
KNOW THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE SOME
OF THE TOUGHEST, WHAT WE DO
HAVE, ACCORDING TO NOVEMBER OR
DECEMBER OR JANUARY, WE ARE
ACTUALLY TRENDING DOWNWARD IN
TERMS OF GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
CITY.
WE ARE VERY HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: LET'S GO THROUGH
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
BALTIMORE SCHOOL SYSTEM BECAUSE
YOU ARE FUNDING 60 BUSES TO GO
DOWN TO THE MARCH.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG --
>> WE ALSO HAVE FUNDING THAT'S
BEING PROVIDED BY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AS WELL AS INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DONATING MONEY SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT ON A
SATURDAY MORNING WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE WANT TO GO TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD THAT THEY ARE ABLE
TO DO THAT.
ABLE TO DO THAT SAFELY.
>> Laura: 'S THE BALTIMORE
SCHOOL --
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW THAT
BUT IT'S NOT WORKING HERE.
>> Laura: THE BALTIMORE SCHOOL
SYSTEM, HERE ARE SOME
STATISTICS.
THE ENROLLMENT IS FALLING NOW TO
A 10-YEAR LOW.
WE HAVE $130 MILLION BUSTED
DEFICIT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT HAS TO
DO WITH A NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE --
>> Laura: LET ME FINISH AND I
WILL TELL YOU WHY.
I'M GOING TO PUT THESE FACTS OUT
THERE.
>> BEING ACTIVE AND HAVING THEIR
VOICES HEARD.
THESE ARE TOMORROW'S VOTERS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THEIR COUNTRY.
THEY WILL BE HEARD ON MARCH
>> Laura: INSUFFICIENT HEAT IN
THE CLASSROOMS.
$38 MILLION NEEDED FOR HVAC AND
OTHER REPAIRS.
115 SCHOOL PERSONNEL LAID OFF.
FIRST TIME WITH THAT TEACHER
LAYOFFS IN TEN YEARS.
>> HOPEFULLY WHEN THEY GET TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO EXPRESS THAT INTEREST AS
WELL.
EXPRESSING THEIR INTEREST TO
HELP OUR CITY.
>> Laura: WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION.
MAYOR, HELLO?
>> WHAT IS THE QUESTION LAURA?
I'M LISTENING, LAURA.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SUFFERING IN
BALTIMORE AS MANY OTHER
METROPOLITAN AREAS ARE AS WELL.
NOT UNIQUE TO BALTIMORE, BUT
NEVERTHELESS YOU ARE SUFFERING
FROM DECLINING ENROLLMENT,
SUFFERING FROM A HUGE BUDGET
DEFICIT WHILE YOUR OFFICE IS
ADDING --
>> WE ARE NOT SUFFERING FROM A
DEFICIT.
>> Laura: $130 MILLION BUDGET
DEFICIT FOR EDUCATION IN THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
>> THAT'S NOT OUR ENTIRE CITY
BUDGET.
>> Laura: YOUR SCHOOLS.
YOUR FUNDING BUSES TO GO DOWN TO
WASHINGTON AND YET YOU HAVE A
BUDGET DEFICIT AND YOU ARE
LAYING OFF.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU ARE
TRYING TO BECOME THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION --
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU'RE GETTING PERSONAL.
>> WE ARE NOT FUNDING -- WE ARE
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO YOUNG
PEOPLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET TO WASHINGTON, D.C., SAFELY.
>> Laura: WHY IS THAT YOUR
JOB?
AS THE MAYOR OF BALTIMORE WHY IS
THAT YOUR JOB TO ASSIST STUDENT
ACTIVIST?
ARE YOU DOING THAT FOR THE MARCH
FOR LIFE NEXT JANUARY?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY THE REASON WHY
I'M DOING IT BECAUSE I AM THE
MAYOR OF MY CITY, BECAUSE I CARE
ABOUT MY CHILDREN.
I WANT THEIR VOICES TO BE HEARD
AND WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., ON MARCH 24TH.
>> Laura: HAVE YOU DONE THAT
FOR THE MARCH FOR LIFE?
HAVE YOU DONE THAT FOR THE
PRO-LIFE MARCH EVERY JANUARY?
>> THE PRO-LIFERS DIDN'T REACH
OUT TO ME.
>> Laura: SO YOU WOULD FIND
THEM NEXT JANUARY?
>> THE CHILDREN OF OUR CITY, OF
OUR COUNTRY REACHED OUT TO ME.
THEY CAME DOWN AND WE OFFERED TO
ASSIST THEM SO THAT THEY CAN GET
TO WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Laura: 'S YOU ARE NOT
SPENDING ANY MONEY?
ALL THE REPORTS ABOUT $100,000
IS FALSE?
>> TOO MANY ASSAULT WEAPONS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
TOO MANY CHILDREN BEING COLD.
TOO MANY PEOPLE BEING KILLED IN
THE STREETS OF OUR CITY SO WE
ARE EXCITED FOR THEM.
AND CERTAINLY ARE GRATEFUL FOR
OFFERING ME TO COME HERE THIS
EVENING.
>> Laura: 13 OF THE 19
BALTIMORE HIGH SCHOOLS HAVE ZERO
STUDENTS TODAY WHO ARE MEETING
GRADE LEVEL PROFICIENCIES?
>> I AM CONCERNED ABOUT EVERY
SINGLE INDIVIDUAL WHO LIVES IN
MY CITY.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT OUR SCHOOLS,
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE FEAR
THAT EXISTS AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY, IN MY CITY
FOR --
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT A BIGGER
PROBLEM THAN TRAINING STUDENT
ACTIVISTS?
>> THERE IS NO BIGGER PROBLEM
THAN HAVING PEOPLE KILLED BY
ASSAULT WEAPONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THERE ARE NO BIGGER PROBLEMS
THAN PARENTS WHO SEE YOUNG
PEOPLE BEING KILLED.
THERE'S NO BIGGER PROBLEM THAN
PEOPLE'S LIVES BEING LOST
BECAUSE OF WEAPONS OF
DESTRUCTION'S ARE ON THE STREETS
OF OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
COUNTRY UNDERSTANDS THAT
VIOLENCE IS NOT THE WAY, ASSAULT
WEAPON SHOULD NOT BE GIVEN TO
PEOPLE AND BACKGROUND CHECKS
NEED TO BE DONE.
>> Laura: JUST SO OUR AUDIENCE
UNDERSTANDS, IN THE FUTURE,
SINCE YOU THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS VOICES TO
BE HEARD, IF CONSERVATIVE
STUDENTS OR PRO-LIFE STUDENTS --
CAN I JUST FINISH A QUESTION
PLEASE?
>> YES, DEAR.
>> Laura: IF PRO-LIFE STUDENTS
GO TO YOU AND ASK YOU TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION OR SUPPORT FOR
ATTENDING CONSERVATIVE MARCHES
BECAUSE THEY WANT THEIR VOICES
HEARD, WILL YOU AS MAYOR OF
BALTIMORE SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS
AS WELL IN THE EDUCATION PROCESS
OR JUST FOR THE STUDENT
ACTIVISTS?
>> LET'S BE REAL CLEAR.
IF THE PRIVATE SECTOR WAS TO
PROVIDE BUSES FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
GO PROTEST ANYTHING IN THIS
COUNTRY THEY ARE WILLING TO
SUPPORT THAT, JUST LIKE THE NRA
SUPPORTS ALL OF THEIR ISSUES.
I SUPPORT THE YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I SUPPORT THE RIGHT OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GO -- I'M
SITTING THERE'S MONEY SPENT
MAKING SURE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE GET
TO WASHINGTON, D.C., SAFELY.
THE BUSES AREN'T FREE.
>> Laura: TEACHERS ARE BEING
FIRED, PERSONNEL ARE BEING LAID
OFF.
YOU JUST HIRED 20 NEW PEOPLE,
INCLUDING A NEW MARKETING
DIRECTOR IN YOUR OFFICE, WHICH
IS GREAT, I'M SURE THEY WILL DO
A GREAT JOB.
TEACHERS ARE GETTING LAID OFF,
PERSONNEL LAID OFF AND YOU ARE
STUDENTS DOWN TO A RALLY.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE SENSE.
>> WE HIRED 22 PEOPLE TO TAKE
CARE OF THE HOME WAS ON OUR
STREETS.
>> Laura: AND A MARKETING
DIRECTOR, CORRECT?
>> WE DID NOT.
A PUBLIC AFFAIRS DIRECTOR.
>> Laura: DOES A LOT OF
REPORTING APPARENTLY THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
YOU ARE NOT SPENDING MONEY TO
SEND KIDS DOWN.
>> TIME ON TELEVISION STATIONS,
ON RADIO STATIONS.
I CAME HERE SO THAT I COULD
SHARE WITH YOU WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN BALTIMORE.
WE ARE VERY EXCITED.
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., AND WE HOPE
THAT YOU WILL BE THERE SO THAT
YOU CAN WELCOME THEM THERE AND
YOU CAN HEAR THEIR VOICES
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THE